hey guys how's it going welcome to ask
IJ I'm Justine I've been doing this show
for a very long time
and it's funny because you guys still
ask me the same questions every single
time so let's hope that today is an
exception probably not
first question oh it's for my girl
Katelyn if you could live in a video
game which one would you live in and why
let me tell you what I would definitely
be the princess because honestly she
just sits around probably eating crumb
cake coffee cake I like coffee and I
like cake coffee cake
just made for Mario to come and save her
I mean it's like sitting around eating
your cake you just magically get taken
and transported to another castle I mean
she's got it made she travels a lot I'm
not really sure I Jennifer what's new of
I'm excited about my own so so happy who
do you being made and yes I am honestly
so ecstatic if you guys don't know the
actual not even wearing one right now
which is kind of crazy the hoodie that I
always wear the little dinosaur hats and
craziness all over we're making an eye
Justine hoodie will be available very
very soon at Comic Con and online so
don't worry I'll let you guys know all
of those details what do you need to
know Maddy what's the weirdest thing
that has happened to you I don't think I
could ever really name one weird thing
that has happened to me because so many
weird random things happen to me every
single day that if I had if I had a
camera actually following me and filming
everything that I ever did like my
reality show would be a legit Kardashian
house you ain't got nothing on the rate
of things that happen to me it's it's so
crazy that I can't even name one right
now Breanna is asking how long
are you I'm great actually thank you for
asking
Gabe wants to know if I wear my Google
glass every day no no I don't really
wear it any days ever actually it's not
one of those novelty things where I just
wear it randomly because I'm not
constantly connected to the Internet so
that I got is because I get the Wi-Fi
and takes the pics and then people ask
me questions they want to put it on
their face and it's linked to my Twitter
to my Google+ to my tumblr so if
somebody pushes one wrong thing they're
tweeting something or tumbling or
whatever and how you don't want them
touching my things
sabrina is asking if I can go back in
time where and when would I go I'd
probably go back to the time of
dinosaurs
I've always loved dinosaurs and I would
like to see a dinosaur so that's
probably what I would choose yeah
Jaime are you playing The Last of Us if
so how is it so far so good I think I'm
about halfway through I I started it
maybe two or three days before it even
came out and I haven't even accomplished
much more after that because I've been
traveling so hopefully sometime soon I
could actually finish the game Lindsey
is asking what my favorite Starbucks
drink is no Lindsay thank you so much
you guys have some great questions today
my favorite rmx drink is pretty much
just a black coffee just straight-up
nothing in it
sip sip usually that's just my go-to
because I don't really like to drink
dairy so if I am going to go crazy and
get a dairy drink it probably would be
only on a chai latte or the hibiscus
refreshers Oh God I think Starbucks now
Isabelle if I was trapped in a house
with nothing but a unicorn Miley Cyrus
and some Angry Birds
what would you do well I would probably
try to get out of that house as soon as
possible or maybe I'd have some bonding
time with Miley I feel like you know
looks pretty cool maybe I don't know I
don't know her
think we'd have fun Emily is asking who
was my favorite in Mortal Kombat
definitely Melina me nah rings okay
always one Travis what will you be doing
at comic-con I'm actually redoing a
bunch of things at Comic Con and I'm so
excited I don't have a couple of meetups
one is going to be I don't think we've
actually announced but that is yet so I
will tell you soon but that has to do
with my show on AOL then next one is
we're going to be debuting myself happy
buddy is at Comic Con and also gonna be
doing the meetup for that so I can't
wait to show it to you so excited and I
think that's actually all the questions
I have if I'm on schedule with posting
my videos I'm currently in London right
now for gfinity its ecology tournament
and I will see you guys in my next video